and you just started school right yes
how is it going congratulations no i'm
loving everything i feel like this whole
year flew by so fast wow yeah
it wasn't everything you expected it was
everything i expected and honestly more
like it was just
everything so i'm so happy to be with
everybody that i like i've just loved
everyone that i've met wow
where do you want to go from here does
the night like tonight make you want to
get into hollywood girl
yes definitely i mean honestly i just
love i'm just love everyone here
was an oscar winner right yes yes so i'm
so excited because they talked about
vanity fair all the time and they're
like oh my gosh like yeah i'm so my well
my mom told me like she's so excited for
me to come here and i'm it made me more
excited to be here
that has to feel like an emotional
moment they talked about it now you're
here how does that feel i'm just so i
don't know just so over the moon yeah
like we got some big names here anybody
you're hoping to meet oh honestly
anybody ever like everyone really and
i'm excited to run into some some people
too oh like yeah hopefully um hopefully
some like close family friends yeah oh
my god is mom here tonight no my mom
isn't here i'm actually so sad she
couldn't be here why can't she she's at
home with my sisters yeah holding down
holding on the floor you know i mean but
she like when she saw you what was her
reaction oh my gosh she was she was so
stunned and i just felt so happy that
she was able to see this oh my gosh
who are you wearing by the way
gucci um what's the secret to the look
we asked everybody the secrets of the
lick ooh what do you any uh anything you
had like some people are like i had to
plank in the car i couldn't sit ooh
um honestly this one actually wasn't any
i didn't have any special tricks
comfortable i'm comfortable i'm
perfect ideal so i'm looking forward to
it yeah how have you guys been i know
you you and your mom and your sisters i
just love following you guys because
you're like the closest most beautiful
family have you been oh thank you um
i've been good i've been good so far
yeah it's been nice to be able to come
back home everyone like every hopefully
every weekend like just be able to like
see family and stuff um to be able to
have that option
we're gonna finish school and then we're
gonna become an actress well i actually
have school tomorrow
um
you're a vanity fair tonight you gotta
go to school tomorrow at 9 a.m
mom be proud she is not skipping class
are you skipping no i won't i will not
be
well i wish mom was here with you but
are you heading home to hang with her
tonight definitely amazing you you two
are just you're so inspirational if
there's a message you have to people at
home about staying strong and and
leaning on each other what is that
message like what have you learned about
how to be strong and continue and
succeed i mean honestly i've learned the
most just from each other um i think
just being able to rely on each other
and be there for each other has been
like the biggest inspiration
[Music]
you